lorsque je regarde ma boussole
elle m'a dit que le nord ces pratiques
ces pratiques de savoir où
vva ces pratiques de savoir comment on y
va et de pouvoir se repart et d'évaluer
son monde évalué le monde d'évaluer son
existence et c'est une question qu'on
peut se poser comment évaluer son
existence et comment en trouver une
direction avec une question très simple
qu'est ce que je veux vraiment pas
évident de savoir ce qu'on veut vraiment
la société elle nous a donné des appuis
en nous disant que la volonté était
espèce de mélange un peu un peu simple
entre une condition sociale imposer des
valeurs comme avoir son baccalauréat je
veux mon baccalauréat parce que la
société me l'a demandé et j'en suis
conscient et on mélange avec ça un désir
très personnel donc par exemple j'arrive
en terminale je veux mon baccalauréat je
veux sortir avec cette personne et si
j'y arrive
j'obtiens ce que je veux vraiment mais
il ya un problème à ça c'est que cette
illusion est maintenue par quelque chose
d' extrêmement pédagogique quelle erreur
pas de manière standard pas une
pédagogie qu'on connaît l'erreur celle
de l'apprentissage non celle de
l'illusion lorsque j'ai chou ça une
vertus extraordinaires
enfin je peux avoir un ancrage en me
disant que si j'avais réussi
j'aurai obtenu ce que je voulais
si j'étais sorti avec cette personne et
pendant 30 ans jour et nuit
je vais penser à un loup à lui en me
disant si j'avais réussi si j'étais avec
je serais heureux ou en tout cas j'aurai
obtenu ce que je voulais si j'étais
j'avais mon bac avec mention très bien
si j'avais obtenu mon diplôme
d'ingénieurs de médecins si dans l'art
j'aurai obtenu ce que je voulais sauf
qu' un problème ça est un problème à
cette illusion que beaucoup de gens
adoptent c'est que parfois il ya des
gens qui réussissent parfois et ben vous
obtenez ce que vous voulez parfois vous
obtenez même tout ce que vous voulez
encore mieux encore plus hélas
l'illusion elle tombe
vous pouvez plus vous dire si j'avais
obtenu non vous sortez avec la personne
que vous voulez sortir
vous avez eu tous les diplômes des mêmes
plus vous avez une consécration sociale
sauf que vous sentez qu'au fond de vous
vous n'avez pas obtenu exactement ce que
vous voulez pas tout à fait alors il ya
deux reflex le premier tout bête et de
dire non mais c'est parce qu'il manque
quelque chose
j'ai eu le bac mais j'ai pas encore
intégré l'école d'ingénieurs bon ok j'ai
intégré l'école d'ingénieurs mais j'ai
pas encore mon diplôme d'ingénieur bon
j'ai obtenu mon diplôme d'ingénieur mais
j'ai pas encore le métier qui me
permettraient de savoir ce que je veux
bon j'ai obtenu le métier que je voulais
mais je commence en bas de l'échelle
il faut augmenter bon j'ai augmenté mais
la consécration viendra vraiment en fin
de carrière et en même temps la carrière
c'est peut-être parce que je voulais
enfin la retraite je pourrais faire et à
voir ce que je veux et là vous arrivez à
la mort bon autant vous dire que là
c'est un mélange entre le temps semble
plus de tantale et de sisyphe et que
vous allez soit vous endormir soit vivre
dans une espèce de frustration
permanente dans une course accélérée
vous savez comme quand vous êtes petit
vous avez des ménages des manèges pour
le tour autour il ya quelque chose qui
me questionner j'étais tout petit ma
mère des jalles me disait arrête de
poser ce genre de questions ça pas
beaucoup de sens j'y mets à temps si
j'arrive à attraper le pompon dans le
manège
qu'est ce qui arrive nous dis moi tu
peux tourner encore une blague marque le
but c'est de tourner sans cesse et les
gamins étaient contents ouais je
continue à tourner étrange mais vous
avez une solution autre que celle de
continuer à tourner de plus en plus vite
en disant bon j'ai cette voiture mais
après j'aurai une voiture plus puissante
et puis le but c'est d'arriver avec une
voiture qui va très vite
bon à la rive au même endroit mais ça
faut pas le dire les gens ne savent pas
il ya celle 40 ami socrate ya longtemps
c'est la connaissance de soi plutôt la
compréhension en gros l'idée c'est
d'essayer de savoir mais vraiment qu'est
ce que je veux de se questionner mais il
ya un problème si je commence à partir
sur la volonté
qu'est ce que je veux vraiment la
volonté semble extrêmement instable j'ai
un ami qui est chirurgien
il a été capable de faire ses études
d'un trait la majorer sa première année
de médecine à montpellier il n'est pas
capable d'arrêter de fumer
comment ça c'est plus dur d'arrêter de
fumer comme majorer la première année de
médecine
ah bon il arrive à monter des des
montagnes mois a déjà la moitié je
manque d'oxygène je meurs il n'est pas
pareil il ya des gens je sais pas vous
avez des présidentielles qui ceux qui
ont une compétence incroyable qu'ils
sont intelligents qui ont vraiment une
volonté de serre et qui sont incapables
de se contenir en terme de moeurs
c'est bizarre c'est à dire une la
volonté serait pas unitaire il y aurait
plusieurs fort de volonté c'est un peu
étrange
et c'est là où je me dis mais comment
c'est pour savoir ce qu'on veut vraiment
parce que cette volonté rationnelle nous
dit pas grand chose la réponse elle est
tout simple vous en êtes déjà aperçu
vous voulez aller là est en fait vous
allez là contrairement un personnage de
bande dessinée qui dit je tiens quelque
chose de la main droite et je fais ça
vous pensez ça et d'un seul coup c'est
la main gauche levée
vous êtes certain de vouloir sortir avec
elle parce qu'elle est gentil elle est
tous allés agréable vous comprends et
vous sortez avec elle et elle vous
ennuie vous êtes certains voulaient
sortir avec lui parce qu'il est sympa il
est gentil il est plein de bonnes idées
et vous sortez avec notre mais
pourquoi c'est parce que je voulais à la
base mais c'est ce que je fais et ben
voilà le secret
arriver à comprendre ce que je veux
non par rapport à ce que je pense dans
ma tête même avec la plus grande
sincérité du monde même si je me
couperait les 80 en disant c'est ça que
je veux non simplement regarder ce que
je fais parce qu'en fait dans ce que je
fais il ya une part d' absurde
il ya une part de une part
d'inconscience une espèce de débilité
profonde mais qui est la source même de
l'imaginaire de lier de l'inconnu il ya
quelque chose qui est issu du monde du
chaos qui n'arrive pas à être domptées
dionysos appelle sa force sauvage et
cette force sauvage plus vous essayez de
la réprimer plus elle va se concentrer
quelque part si vous voyez quelqu'un
être parfait méfiez-vous la force
sauvage va s'exprimer
donc plein maintenant je vous dis ça me
dit bah voilà vous pouvez évaluer ce que
vous voulez vraiment comment par la jirs
l'action quotidien ce que vous avez fait
dans votre vie vous pouvez avoir un
réflexe en disant ah non non non non non
moi j'ai fait des trucs mais en fait je
ne voulais pas c'est le hasard
j'ai des preuves j'ai des preuves que
moi je voulais aller là mais que le ciel
m'est tombé dessus je suis allé là ça me
rappelle un exemple d'un psychanalyste
qui disait que tous les tous les mois de
juin l'un de ces patients se casser la
jambe
tous les mois de juin ça a duré dix ans
tous les mois de juin la jambe gauche
était et est alors souvent osé dire oui
je comprends il part faire une randonnée
glisser tout en mai une fois un vase lui
est tombé sur la jambe sur la cuisse au
mois de juin dans la rue vous avez deux
compréhension à ça la première en aspe
métaphysique ou y aurait des forces et
la deuxième un peu plus simple il ya une
force en vous même en terme de calcul
elle est extrêmement puissante et quand
elle veut exprimer quelque chose quand
elle veut vous dire quelque chose
elle va le faire elle va faire des
choses que vous pensez être issu du
hasard mais qui ne l'est pas et quand
vous comprenez ça vous comprenez qu'il
est indispensable de mettre en travail
cette force là c'est à dire cette
volonté issus de l'absurde pour
comprendre ce que vous voulez vraiment
mais maintenant que je voulais dit
nettoyage
on est en train de me dire que je suis
un peu débile je suis un peu absurde de
quoi ça me sert ça ça vous sert à
quelque chose d'indispensable
la première vous aurez le sentiment
profond que vous faites ce que vous
voulez et ça ça n'a pas de prix que vous
pouvez mourir maintenant vous avez fait
sur terre ce que vous voulez il n'y a
pas d' après ça ça n'a pas de prix et le
second qui est quelque chose d'encore
plus extraordinaires je vous prends un
exemple vous êtes dans les années 70
c'est un jeune réalisateur un artiste un
peu fou et au milieu de la nuit fait
eurêka j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé je vais faire un space opéra
avec des types d guerrier en armure en
plastique des me pète et dont le héros
est un paysan qui fait de la télékinésie
ça va s'appeler gare les étoiles quoi
pas la bataille des cailloux débile ton
truc tout le monde lui a dit c'est
débile et quand il a mené les premiers
rushes en route tous les ses amis
réalisateurs et compris spielberg mais
on dit ça c'est un nanar ça mon amie et
quand vous voyez la première réalisation
du premier star wars tous les acteurs
considèrent qu'ils tournent dans un
nanar
mais à la différence de ceux qui dans la
nuit en plein d'espoir mais qui se
réveille au matin en rationalisant
disant non c'est pas n'importe quoi
il y a des gens qui ont travaillé leur
absurdité pour être source d'un
renouveau bien sûr ils vont produire des
choses un peu débile ça arrive mais en
même temps ils vont faire quelque chose
de nouveau
ils vont y vont
porter l'humanité vers de nouvelles
valeurs une nouvelle voix quelque chose
qui adapte l'humanité un nouveau monde
qui change malgré lui faut pas s'y
tromper c'est pas l'humanité qui est à
la barre cnis du climat ni de quoi que
ce soit on n'a jamais eu ce pouvoir par
contre on a le pouvoir ne pas comprendre
que si on ne s'adapte pas en ces temps
et là vous allez dépasser le concept
même de ce que nietzsche appelle les
espèces de vérité c'est-à-dire
l'ingénierie tourner de plus en plus
vite et d'autres plus en plus
spécialisés être capable de faire les
choses de mieux en mieux mais dans un
espace de plus en plus restreint vous
devenez le koala qui ne peut manger que
l'eucalyptus à faire autrement faire
différemment être celui qui a accepté sa
part d' absurdité pour enfin faire
quelque chose de nouveau
[Musique]
et voilà comment on peut savoir ce que
l'on veut vraiment merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]